[Music]
well we all know that Tick Tock has been
a Scourge on society it's ruining our
kids minds and souls turning them into
zombies China is spying on us it's been
a disaster but it's been great for
content and that's all that really
matters hello I like money and so this
is a little bit of a retrospective for
tick tock as we head into the new year
let's go back and watch again and
reflect briefly upon
the worst tick tocks of the year or best
depending on
how you look at it no introduction
needed for these videos you'll you'll
remember many of them these are the uh I
guess we'll do the six six worst tick
tocks why six because it brings to mind
666 the Number of Satan seems to apply
so let's uh get into it controversial
opinion but if you have a token white
and you're hanging out with your friend
group of color
you need to ask permission from
in the group to bring your white friend
like don't just bring them ask for
explicit permission from everyone
because just because you're comfortable
with them doesn't mean that everybody's
comfortable with them I might not be in
the mood to deal with white shenanigans
that day that's that's all I'm saying
and another thing it feeds into their
ego like don't don't let them think
they're a good white person don't don't
give them that card to use against other
people please don't do that I do
appreciate at least the phrase white
Shenanigans maybe that'll be my one day
that'll be the the title of my Memoir
white Shenanigans the irony here of
course is that the is that this person
what is her name Sriracha lesbian
see exactly that's the person nobody
wants to be around so whenever someone
is like oh hey should I invite Sriracha
lesbian to out tonight everyone goes her
no why would you do that we don't want
to be around her you know if this is a
white woman doing a video about how if
you are in a white friend group you
should ask permission before inviting
your black friend because not all of
your white friends will be in the mood
for black Shenanigans if she said that
it would just she'd literally go to
prison for that
hi kids there's no such thing as a boy
or a girl and I can prove it so gather
around the family the parents everybody
answer my questions you either say boys
or girls who's usually taller
oh boys okay but you've met some short
boys right you met some tall girls so
usually boys are taller but not always
okay who likes the color pink
girls okay
um but you've met girls who don't like
pink and you met boys who do like pink
so usually girls like pink but not
always
everything you can think of that makes a
boy or makes a girl
is usually but not always
some of them are not even usually
where does that leave you
free you get to like what you like you
get to be who you are
maybe you're even like me and you're not
a boy or a girl
oh yes it's our friend from Silence of
the Lambs there uh in a way I'm I'm
always impressed with this guy because
it's not easy to be the creepiest son of
a [ __ ] on the Internet it's a bit like
being the fattest guy at Golden Corral
it's you have to work for that you've
got to earn that one and this guy is
working hard
[Music]
but let's not allow that to distract us
from the fact of just how nonsensical
his point is in this video you know he
says that there is No Such Thing
remember that's the claim there is no
such thing as a boy or girl because some
girls don't like color pink and some
boys aren't taller than girls I once saw
a [ __ ] elephant that was smaller than
a horse therefore elephants and horses
don't exist
that's not how this works like in order
for boys to exist and girls to exist
that doesn't mean that every single boy
has to look it doesn't mean that they
all have to be identical twins no one's
claiming that the entire world is made
up of identical there's identical boys
and identicals and that's all that
exists no one is saying
is a category and then there are many
variations within the category another
inspiring message from Tick Tock welcome
to a day in my life as a Twitter
employee so this past week went to SF
for the first time at a Twitter office
badged in honestly took a moment to just
soak everything in what a blessing also
started my morning off with an iced
matcha from the perch then I had a
meeting so it's quickly scheduled one of
these little pod rooms which were so
cool they're literally noise canceling
took my meeting got ready for a bunch
look how delicious this food looks oh my
goodness I was so overwhelmed then made
my way down to this Log Cabin area I
don't know what this is but it was
really cool quite simply smell with my
friends to kind of unwind a bit
um also found this really cool
meditation room that I thought was super
neat
um I didn't do any yoga but they have
this yoga room if you are a yogi so I
also thought that was really cool
um had a couple more meetings in the
afternoon had a ton of projects that we
needed to knock out say hi to my
teammates
[Music]
um went to the went to the library to
kind of get some more work done
obviously had to have our afternoon
coffee so made some espresso all right
that's what simpler times for that
Twitter employee may she rest in peace
assuming that she's one of the ones who
got fired which I think we can assume
that she is because I mean after all she
apparently had projects she needed to
knock out and yet she had spent the
entire day up until that point
meditating and playing foosball yeah I
had some uh mocha latte and I was
drinking some wine I was mad at those I
had it went for a picnic
play some video games took a quick nap
and then we knocked out some projects
your your job is in trouble like you are
you are not an indispensable member of
the team if you have time in the day for
foosball
and many Twitter employees after that
video shortly after the video was
published they learn that lesson the
hard way well if you're someone who has
always wanted to read the Bible and
understand the Bible but you're not sure
where to start then check out the Bible
in a year podcast from Ascension Bible
New Year podcast is currently the most
popular religion podcast in the US
millions of people have listened to it
and twice it's hit the number one spot
on Apple podcast in the Bible in a year
uh father Mike Schmitz reads the entire
Bible in 365 daily episodes providing
helpful commentary reflection and prayer
along the way what better way to start
the new year you can find the Bible in a
year podcast with father Mike Schmitz
for free in your favorite podcast app or
on YouTube plus you can follow along
with a special reading plan to help you
better understand the story unlike any
other Bible podcast Bible in the air
follows a special reading plan that
organizes the books of the Bible in a
way that helps listeners understand the
story and get this reading plan at
ascensionpress.com Walsh if you want to
start reading more importantly
understanding the Bible this year go to
ascensionpress.com Walsh to download the
reading plan for free
ascensionpress.com Walsh to download the
reading plan for free you know what I
think we need a good old-fashioned sleep
s reliving the moments of girlhood that
I missed out on including sleepovers
where I could be silly with my friends
all night long without a care in the
world so I put together a Dylan
sleepover Essentials list on instacart
that y'all can shop to get my dream
sleepover experience
[Music]
my order is here
I have the delivery first things first
skin care and I'm warning you beforehand
I eat mostly junk food but we're having
a sleepover so it's allowed oh the
pizza's ready
I guess I actually have to correct
myself because I said that the other guy
was the creepiest son of a [ __ ] on the
internet but actually Dylan Mulvaney
holds that title so I do apologize to
Dylan Mulvaney for that totally why not
cut off your skin to wear to my birthday
uh the other guy is then uh you know
analogous to only the second fattest guy
at Golden Corral which is the worst
thing that you could be you might as
well just be skinny at that point and uh
Dylan Mulvaney of course famous for his
um imitation Woman face
probably one of the defining things of
2022 which tells you everything you need
to know about this year I suppose
even another job
have you take this home and work on it
tonight okay respectfully Susan I'd
rather spend time with my family
Veronica did you just decline the zoom
meeting that's at 6 30 tonight
oh yeah I did I did do that yeah because
it's outside of my working hours nine to
five so I won't be attending
all right Veronica I do need you to be
available during your vacation okay
and you'll be blocked on my vacation
okay Veronica I'm gonna need you to
complete all this today
do I look like two people to you no
oh okay just making sure because that
looks like the work of two people right
right and I'm one I'm just one person
right
and it's time to go home five o'clock
hey thank you bye the most annoying Tick
Tock of the Year this is the of course
the accurate phenomenon otherwise known
as quiet quitting you know it's it's not
going to benefit you to be both
obnoxious and lazy on the job you might
be able to get away with one or the
other okay so if you're lazy but you're
also really uh a pleasure to be around
and you're very personable and very nice
and people like you then you you might
you might survive you might actually be
able to Coast through and find some
measure of success in life just based on
it's a risk okay but you might be able
to do it on the other hand if you're
totally obnoxious and miserable and
people hate you but you work hard and
you're very good then you might be able
to skate by that way because they can't
get rid of you because of the work that
you do
combining both of those things together
as this woman has done that's uh then
you're totally relying on affirmative
action and uh diversity equity and
inclusion to save you and to bring you
to to you know be the thing that escorts
you towards success in life if you're a
white man that's not on the that's not
in the car it's not on the table
for her maybe
I don't think she checks enough identity
boxes to get away with it if you decide
to live that way
don't come back around complaining
when you are a total failure in life
because this is the path that you have
chosen and also don't ask for me to pay
for your student loans
all right let's get to our last one
I
have thin privilege
but I'm so fat I'm like a size 20 22.
how can I possibly have thin privilege
because there are people who are fatter
than me when I go up on a plane I might
need a seatbelt extender I might be
uncomfortable I may not feel good people
may say things to me
but I don't need to buy a second seat or
risk getting kicked off the plane
that means that I have privilege
compared to people who have that
experience
you may not even need a seatbelt expand
extender if that's the case then you
have privilege compared to me
somebody who is a model size may have
privilege compared to you
but that doesn't mean you don't have any
privilege almost all of us have some sin
privilege it's a spectrum and it goes by
degrees
you have thin privilege if you only need
one seat belt extender on the plate if
you don't need a second seat belt
extender then you count as thin now uh
once that happens it's just like the
game is over and there are no standards
anymore
all that being said you know there are
if you would like
um uh privileges to being actually thin
or at least not morbidly obese you don't
have to turn sideways to fit through a
door frame like that's you might say a
privilege compared to the alternative
but here's the thing it's also it's
accessible to anyone this is not being
born with a silver spoon this is not the
privilege of someone who's uh you know a
trust fund baby kind of thing that's not
accessible to everyone either your trust
fund baby or not but this is accessible
to anyone so if there is thin privilege
if that concept makes sense the good
news is anyone can have it price of
admission is a salad
and some sit-ups and that's how you have
it
so
all the brands of crazy I think uh
covered in these tick tocks many more
where those came from um it was all in
all a psychotic year on Tick Tock and
across the country
and we're looking forward to uh to an
even more Darkly insane and depressing
year
next year so happy New Year
[Music]